say our screen presentation effectively
yes we see it okay very good so uh yeah
so I'm Jason and uh I have been working
in Vietnam since 2006 uh in
collaboration with friends at Kanto
University uh have worked there on a
range of different basically soil
related projects
um but firstly with ACR there on a rice
shrimp project looking at sustainability
of the right shrimp system uh and then
that led on to what we call the focus
project which is farmer options for
crops under saline conditions
uh and with me uh I have uh Brooke who
who is post-doc on that project so hi
everyone I also have worked in vet um
for a while but started in 2015 as part
of my undergraduate and I have
progressed through after getting my PhD
and now work full-time on this Focus
project and
um interested in soil plants sort of
microbial interactions so it's a great
great space to explore this
but yeah so uh yeah the project is
funded by Asia and uh and uh it's LED in
Australia by us at Charles State
University and our
um in-country lead is um Kento
University
so
um just as a brief intro because the
delta in Vietnam is hugely important to
the country uh it's about 12 of the area
um very flat area and so it is all
pretty much less than four meters above
sea level except for a few Hills or the
locals called mountains
um but yeah so a lot of it's a lot of
it's even less than two meters above sea
level
agriculture is hugely important to the
economy in in the Delta
um with 80 uh of the of the jobs
associated with agriculture in some way
and the Delta produces over 50 of the
country's rice
um production and a lot of that is
exported as well so the economic value
is is quite large
so
um the foodball food bowl of Vietnam is
the Delta
however
um
over the recent years there's been
competition for the water that's coming
down through the Mekong River so with
Upstream water use uh and damming we've
had due to climate change uh drought is
a lot more uh regular now and even the
rainfall patterns have been disrupted so
so 10 years ago the dry and wet season
were very set whereas now they're
they're quite variable and unpredictable
which causes problems of course to the
farming the cropping systems
sea level rise is an issue
um being close to the equator and and so
the seawater eyes has been recorded as
being about 12 to 14 millimeters per
year
and of course as the sea water rises the
salt water starts coming up through the
canal and river system and so
um in this diagram in the map here you
can see that there's lines that show the
extent of salinity coming through
um into the Delta Inland up Upstream up
canals and salinizing the land and so
you can kind of see there in 2010 you
know and it's around the coastal areas
or pericosal areas 2016 was a rather
large drought uh effect and salinity
really started to impact rice crops and
farmers were were in a lot of trouble
because they they never experienced this
before in some areas because it had
moved so far inland and you can see
there in 2020 it happened again
and even further in some areas and so
you literally have a situation where
people who have been able to farm a
certain way for decades all of a sudden
uh were starting to be impacted by this
sea water rise on the salt water
intrusion coming up the canal system and
of course their response once that
happened was okay I can't irrigate from
the river anymore because it's saline so
old groundwater pump instead and of
course removing water from a Delta
system uh makes the land subsidence
worse and so whilst the sea water rise
is that 12 to 14 millimeters per year
land subsidence is around 40 millimeters
per year and so the net effect of that
of course is around 50 mils millimeters
a year in a system where you are two
meters above sea level so that's like
that's pretty that's a bad situation and
that's the situation that we're working
in and of course the problem is that
um that salinity and the effect of the
drought uh basically you have hundreds
of thousands of hectares impacted by by
salt and by lack of water and you have
all that loss of production uh loss of
fun farm income and impact on
communities rural communities so that's
our problem
and of course this the worst of this
situation the the worst of the saltwater
intrusion and the drought uh occurs in
the dry season so in in a lot of areas
through the Delta they'll grow three
crops of rice a year and and our problem
is largely in this early dry season uh
situation and so uh it's this third rice
crop that gets often will get killed by
the salinity but even in areas where
they grow two rice crops they stretch
that out such that that second rice crop
is still susceptible uh in some years to
to impact spice salt so our what we're
looking at is alternatives to rice in
this dry season period uh and the the
farmers that that we work with and the
the darts of the Department Of
Agricultural and rural development
government agencies that we work with
they all say you can
teach us to grow new crops we can use
new soil techniques uh but the the crop
has to be valuable we have to it has to
have a stronger market value than rice
because we can grow more rice and the
farmers will still be poor so the
alternative has to be has to be a
marketable profitable crop and so we
focus on that as well
so in looking at these alternative crops
um we look at the crop but also the soil
management and the agricultural
management of the field to to be able to
grow those crops so we've kind of got
the biophysical the the crop the
selection of the crop species and also
variety and then the soil management
that supports that that that crop and
that sort of thing Brook will go into
more detail but we're talking about
raised beds to minimize the effects of
of water logging mulches to minimize
evaporation and decrease the effects of
salinity for example uh and then of
course there's nutrition on top of that
uh we are looking at the socioeconomic
value chain sort of market analysis so
you know if we grow these crops is there
a market for them what are those markets
what are the barriers to adoption of
those crops within the supply chain uh
so we're examining those within the
project
we need to have a really good
understanding of how salinity of the
soil and the waterways changes through
time and space and so uh if you look
through the literature and online you'll
see maps of the Delta that change that
show salinity but often they're created
by monitoring points in the waterways
and not actually measuring salt in soil
or salinity in soil and so we're looking
at doing that
um you know by a range of different
mechanisms and so we have a team of
people who actually measure salinity in
soil and also the waterways but we also
are doing it with remote sensing as well
because we have a really strong
GIS team that's capable of doing that
sort of stuff for us and so the value of
doing that is we we can understand what
can we grow where can we grow it in
under what conditions and then with that
spatial temporal mapping we actually can
match up where you're going to get a
large enough scale of land to support
those new crops to maybe then inform
government to say look you can support
Private Industry here or change policy
to to create incentives for businesses
to come in and fill this nice part of
the supply chain to enable uh uptake of
this alternative crop and give it a
value
um and then the fourth part is we're
looking at
um the role of gender in the whole
process from uh knowledge Creation in
the research team through to the
extension to Growers the uptake on farm
and also within Supply chains as well
um understanding that it's a really
rapidly moving space and often that
impacts genders differently and so we
need to just understand what we're
dealing with there and and how can we
help offset some of the changes that are
going to be occurring
cool so for the purpose of this
presentation we'll focus on the
biophysical aspect of the project
and that comes down to looking at
alternative crops to Rice to suit this
dry season period so when we first
started out we had to make a criteria
that we could identify crops that could
be suitable uh to start with it was
saline tolerant crops so obviously
towards the end of the dry season the
saline intrusion is is really gets quite
high and soil salinization is the worst
during that later reproductive phase so
salt tolerant crops that can grow and
reproduce and then create a profitable
yield was a criteria we looked at
what are you sufficient crops or crops
that used lower amounts of water to
complete their life cycle was something
that was really important you can get
crops that are salt tolerant but use a
lot of water and in a system where
there's fresh water scarcity it's just
not suitable
um there's a risk there's a higher risk
of failure
we also needed crops that could fit the
climates of the Mekong Delta in that dry
season the temperatures can get to 35
degrees we get these variable very low
rainfall patterns you're relying on
irrigation so these sort of crops that
fit there not not a crop that's a cold
tolerant sort of crop
they had to be able to work in with the
available labor that exists in these
small holder Farms there are some crops
that can fit both the salt tolerant and
water use efficient criteria but require
great amounts of manual labor and that
just doesn't work in the system so
finding something that we can adapt with
the available mechanization and tools
available to Farmers
and most of all as as Jason said it had
to be something that is profitable at
the end of the day for the farmers
because they need a yield to sell at
Market
um otherwise there's there's no point in
investing in this so we sort of based
um uh our crop selection of these
criteria came up with a few different
um species to test and understanding
that this there's there will always be
more species we can't test them all but
we can look at the adoption protocols
and practices of how that occurs
so we
um did a range of glass house and
Greenhouse trials both in Australia and
Vietnam and these helped us sort of work
out
um the salinity and drought or water use
screening of different species
as well as once we identified species
the varieties available in Vietnam that
could be best suited to those perhaps
different spatial areas there may be
areas that are sale unaffected but has
lots of water
and there are varieties that suit that
alternatively there are areas of the
Delta that have less saline intrusion
but water is an issue so you sort of
suit varieties to those areas
we also yes did water use efficiency
sort of screening and through all of
those we did things like measuring plant
and soil parameters
um lots of different
relief indexes prolens yields biomasses
Roots nodules all those sorts of things
from here the range of trials that we
did it helped us establish what we could
use in the field and so some of the
crops we've trialled cow pee there's a
legume beetroot watermelon Maize quinoa
we've we've done a range of different
crops and we utilize the information
from The Glass House and Greenhouse
trials and to work out where they are
best suited in the delta
we have trials across uh it's a transect
across the Delta starting in sock Trang
which is quite close to the coast where
saline intrusion is the worst all the
way up to Ang Yang where it's a broader
scale cropping systems freshwater
scarcity is more of an issue rather than
saline intrusion so there's an adoption
of different species there
we have these dry season trials and then
it goes back into rice cropping after
we're finished and we are looking at
both the performance of our alternative
species and then things like the impacts
of that on Rice afterwards as well as
you know different varieties where they
suit where they're best located
so with those field trials we've got the
species that we've selected but we've
also looked at different management
practices that we can use to enhance the
and optimize the growth of these
alternative crops
the we use a soil monitoring moisture
device called chameleon soil moisture
sensors and these are australian-made
and I'll go into detail in the next
slide but we help farmers understand
irrigation schedules they're familiar
with growing rice which is obviously
flood irrigation these Upland crops
different water requirements we can make
more efficient water decisions and so
we're using these tools to test those
thresholds there
uh rice straw mulching
um different mulching trials we're doing
rate trials combinations with things
like compost and biochar
um chameleons so monitoring irrigation
with mulch so it's just integrating
these different management practices in
things like raised beds as you can see
in one of the pictures up the top there
so
chameleons are a pretty cool device they
are developed originally by csiro in
Australia and now they're sold through
the virtual irrigation company Academy
which is a non-for-profit organization
they measure soil moisture through soil
tension and the beauty about this is
rather than interpreting
um
something that could be complex to a
farmer is in a reading in kilopascals it
comes up with a traffic light system to
indicate the level of soil moisture
that's there
and this makes it really easy to use it
provides real-time data back to the
farmer and it's relatively cheap
compared to things like tensiometers
uh they are however limited by um quite
high levels of salinity and where
working to see where those sort of
thresholds exist and how they fit in
with our system
so the traffic light system just very
quickly blue is
um it's been calibrated to mean you've
got a soil tension between zero and
minus 22 kilobasicals so your soil is
essentially wet you don't need to
irrigate it
brain is moist and once a farmer sees
the red lights come up they know they
have to irrigate you can have a multiple
different layers so that each light
corresponds to its own sensor and that
sensor can be put at different depths so
you could have zero to five five to ten
ten to Fifteen centimeters or we use
them spatially because we've got shallow
rooted species we might use them between
treatments to determine what irrigation
is happening there so it's just it's a
really useful tool for Farmer engagement
and as an educational tool but also a
research tool for us
so
um there is a chameleon card version
which is a cheaper
um method of it but it doesn't log data
like the Wi-Fi one does so you can see a
farmer here um in Vietnam
I think the video will play the lights
flashing so he attaches the wire and
then it will indicate I think a green
light there so hopefully he doesn't go
and irrigate that crop but um yeah super
super easy to use so that's what we're
sort of
um utilizing in our field trials yeah
and without without that intervention
the the farmer Behavior that's been
observed is they irrigate every day
because they think they have to and
they've got no other information to say
that they that's not a good idea but
we've used The Chameleons to show to
demonstrate that actually you don't need
to irrigate every day
yeah so when
um this is just an example of sort of a
field trial experiment we've got set up
and we have what we would call the
Pharma practice which is that irrigating
every day or whatever they perceive as
their ideal irrigation and and what
we've found is it is follow something
along the lines of what they would do
with rice and then we compare that to
our treatments of a chameleon with no
straw and then various rates of straw
mulch to see what water savings we can
get and it's been we've done this over a
few years now and the results are really
consistent and exciting
we have found Enzo
um we'll report uh beetroot or red beets
whatever you'd like to call it
um this is just some from a recent trial
that we did and along the y-axis you can
see the water applied so that's how much
water over the growing season that
um this trial used and we used farmers
in there so we're engaging the farmers
in the field trials and getting sort of
buying there
we can see your First Column is a
chameleon with no Mulch and um so that
was you know you're irrigating based off
what the chameleon says but you don't
have any mulch the next one is the same
it's chameleon but you've got seven tons
of rice straw there and that's then
compared to a farmer's irrigation with
10 tons of mulch so more mops than the
chameleon one yeah so our seven ton was
something that we came up with with our
experiments sort of demonstrated that
seven tons was the optimal optimal rate
for rice rice straw mulch whereas the
farmers were doing tent hunt as their
standard practice so that's why that
rate is different a bit of a comparison
we're trying to also show there's
efficiencies hopefully through less
labor and straw and use like that and
this was this was really cool because we
had here's our beetroot yields in tons
per hectare and you can see
um mulching makes a huge difference so
chameleon no mulch is significantly less
yield
but the chameleon with seven tons per
hectare and then the farmer irrigation
with 10 tons there was no yield
difference so the take-home message is
that you can use less water and less
straw
if you use a chameleon and you get the
same yield and we've had this
um not just across with beetroot we've
had it with Maize watermelon we're
extending that now into you know cow pea
and quinoa so it's exciting to show the
farmers these benefits they don't have
to water every day you don't have to put
on as much straw but you still get you
know the same yields that you would if
you used that much water and that much
mulch so so this is this is really
um it's just a feel-good moment when you
see this data
so what we know from from where we are
at this point in the project is that we
have found
um alternative crops work and as I've
mentioned before
you know people approach us all the time
with different crops you know have you
tried this have you tried that we're not
there to find um
the one crop that will save everything
it's the principle of how we Implement
and adopt new crops and the criteria
that we need to focus on and how we can
work that into a system that's been
predominantly rice based for for many
many years so we've grown these crops
novel crops in areas that have not seen
alternative crops and they work which is
good too and they're profitable
profitable yeah yeah be true I don't
have the quote here but we interviewed
this Farmer in the picture and he made I
think 27 million Dong per
um 1000 meters squared compared to Rice
which was two or three thousand so
significant increases in farm income
which is fantastic and and I think the
next Point
um you get that water saving if you
combine some management practices to
help optimize those crops there will be
um there's many other things that you
can do but these are two
uh achievable and accessible tools for
Farmers they have rice straw chameleons
are relatively cheap we're looking at
ways we can you know get more of these
tools out to Farmers or increase
awareness of irrigation
the seven ton mulch seems to be the
magic number consistently throughout our
trials 10 tons it either you know it
doesn't improve yield or improve
anything so that's a good threshold to
know and we sort of work from from that
now
um it's better than two and a half tons
but but seven tons is no better than ten
so that's that's um useful to know
and we have found that 25 saving in
labor and that would be
um through irrigation like not having to
irrigate daily
um you can get that back to a household
and we have interviews where Farmers
have said that they now have more time
to take their grandchildren to school
and things like that so there's social
benefits as well
as well as um 25 Savings in fuel and
that's from running pumps and things
like that so there are all these sort of
other benefits to the alternative crops
and the management practices that we're
looking at however there are still of
course things that we still need to know
and and need to find these out and these
are research questions of Interest
timing being a big one so the
um finding those sewing Windows where we
avoid abiotic stresses like temperature
the saline intrusion those sort of water
limitations they they are really
important in to fit in with a cropping
calendar that of rice that's already
there no and that's a really big
challenge because
um because one of the effects of the
climate change is the unpredictable
weather yeah so in our in our journey
working there the last few years we've
had the early storm events that have
flooded types and we've had the the heat
wave effects that you know kill
seedlings whereas you know the year
before that didn't happen and so
um and when you talk to the farmers has
it been this hot before and they've
never seen it this hot before so things
are changing and so
um that unpredictability is a real issue
for us trying to fit these new crops
into into the system yeah and then as
Jason said it's fitting them into the
system and then fitting them into their
cultural practices so Vietnam has a big
holiday in the in our new year but it's
it's tet and when you speak to Farmers
or researchers they say no one will grow
crops over that period because they
require irrigation daily and everyone
takes two weeks off or ten days so it's
working out it's you know we might have
the scientific answer but it's how that
fits into a socio sort of
um Family household Dynamic practice and
and the implications of changing
something like that we have to sort of
look into that as well
and then
um on top of that it's then optimizing
once we've sort of got the timing right
and it fits into a cycle that works for
the farmers how can we optimize those
um plants alternative crops is it
fertilizer is it you know are we looking
at soil constraints those sorts of
things the soil is has been growing rice
for many years there's probably
um micronutrient research macronutrient
there's there's a whole gamut of
optimization that could go into that to
further
um in a way that's low input and and
high productivity high profitability for
Farmers
um those are the sort of questions that
we're looking at in the future and of
course those alternative crops if they
have benefit to the subsequent rice crop
that means that you can wind back the
fertilizer inputs then you change the
risk profile because now you don't have
so much Capital invested in in
fertilizer for example and so the you
know if the crop fails the losses aren't
as great so there's those sort of things
to take account of as well
yeah so with that that's um a nice
little wrap-up of our project and our
um team and fantastic team members in
Vietnam who really do a great job of
pulling all these field trials and
research questions together for us so
it's it's a great place to work and
explore these um these big big picture
questions yeah thanks for the
opportunity to present
thank you very very much uh for this
wonderful presentation I enjoyed it a
lot and have a few questions myself but
I will give the floor first to others
questions please also comments are
welcome
suggestions and Stefan is first
yeah I know a great presentation and a
lot of learning for us in the Asia Mecca
Delta initiative so linking up is really
really useful valuable and hope we can
do this further going forward together
uh that's just one comment but my
question
uh is a little bit around the choices
that you made that the initial crops
that you tested did you do some sort of
market analysis before because uh you
sort of didn't talk about that that's
fine but just to know that you do a
market that's beat-root Market out there
there's a potential there or for the
melon or whatever it may be quinoa Etc
over yes yeah so we we didn't as far as
we knew that we couldn't do every single
crop and so we grouped them into sort of
you know serial types or grain crops
vegetables and did it that way
um but um what's what's what I've
learned out of that process is that the
scale of operation matters a lot and so
there are some small small farms where
perhaps the more labor-intensive niche
uh like beetroot or something like that
which they can sell locally at a at a
high price works for that small farm
whereas if that was done on a bigger
Farm the the higher labor requirement
more labor units all of a sudden that's
not economical anymore whereas if you
move somewhere to a larger scale then
mechanization becomes super important
and something like quinoa is viable
whereas it's not viable on a small farm
because you know it's
you need to be mechanized to actually
make that function and so
um
so whilst we're doing those we are doing
those supply chain studies
um we we started with the agronomic to
get the ball rolling uh in that and now
we can refine and probably chase the
winners a little bit better if that
makes sense yeah and I think matching up
um existing small markets households you
know the growth of vegetables sold on
the side of the road you understand
there's a familiar parity there
um and it's just as Jason said matching
that to where those smaller communities
might exist or if it's broader scale and
you can get Harvesters in yeah
thanks I my question is actually very
similar so I I use my current power to
jump the line a bit sorry Mike
um how did you come up with the actual
crops that you were testing or that you
tested in the in the field I mean you
you showed the requirements and kind of
the the general
um yeah framework that they should
should meet but that's probably still I
mean dozens of options available did you
sit down and brainstorm or did you have
like a process for that that you ask
experts come to University what was the
so so we so we had we had the literature
we had you know what's possible from the
literature we worked very closely and
and it's my mistake I have not got that
on my um my final slide there in terms
of who's in the team but the the dad the
the department of agricultural rural
development we actually worked really
strongly with the the field staff there
to hear what they wanted what they are
interested in or their farmers are
interested in and so so we like I guess
quinoa we bought bought in as like that
didn't come from Vietnam as an idea but
but
um everything else is pretty much the
the farmers were interested or the dard
staff have seen it grown somewhere else
and wondered is that possible
um and so so yeah it was ground up a lot
of the cases but we had the literature
there to sort of fill in well this
should work and that should work or
um when we didn't want to we didn't want
to reinvent the wheel so if you know
people have grown tomatoes then fine we
already know you can do that and so and
and just a quick follow-up was the is it
General generally crops that hey are
grown in the Mekong Delta already
because sometimes you also mention new
crops so what's the
the mix between crops that maybe not
those Farmers but that were kind of
common in the Mekong Delta and
completely new ideas
you know the Patriots knew and quinoa's
new so yeah so they're out there our
newbies
um but yeah the um cowpea we were really
Keen to get a legume in the system
soybean was our recommended from Dad and
we with our sort of knowledge of the
literature we tested soybean but knowing
that it's only moderate salt tolerance
and and consequently it failed so
looking then they they're interested in
a legume what can we find that fits that
growing calendar and it's as you know
shorter duration was also a big
requirement trying to get something that
can get through its reproductive phases
and avoid those abiotic stresses so
cowpe was was great because it's a
multi-purpose crop and finding crops
that have
um Beyond one benefit whether it's
because it's a legume or it could be
used as a forage crop or it could be
harvested as a bean consumed as a
vegetable those sorts of things became
appealing and then the farmers really
got on board with that which is great so
it's sort of a yeah you know the
suggestions are passed in and we try and
optimize what crops might suit that and
if it's um if there's longer term Legacy
effects as well through a nitrogen
fixation I mean what a win for the
system okay so so it's a it's a mixed
methods approach yeah yeah okay
Mike uh you've been very patient
yeah thanks very much and thank you for
a very interesting presentation my angle
comes from the Aquatic side the the
fishy side
rather than crops but of course
recognizing that the the Integrated
Systems
rice fish and other crops fish uh is are
of course interesting for for Delta
environments today and on another one CG
uh program called asean
we're looking at among other things uh
regenerative agriculture which have
involved soil health
and sometime back James quilty who you
know from acir
asked me and others to evaluate a rice
shrimp project which I think you were
also involved with
and
that work promoted a Bayesian belief
network uh probability app
so my first question is is that
application still in use and are farmers
finding it useful
uh um so I'm not I'm not sure on the um
the uptake of of the BBN app I know
they're very interested I know they've
wanted it it was one of the things that
we we need this
um but I'm not sure how far that got
developed after that project ended
um but we had it set up we got it to a
point where we had the structure there
it functioned but like any any decision
support system it's it's value improved
with data going into it and so I'm not
sure how much has has happened since the
project ended
okay thank you and the next question
part of the question is have you come
across something called a biofunk tool
it measures soil health
by gathering a range of
um soil properties to give a prediction
about soil health
uh short answer no but one of the things
that we've um
we work with the farmers because we
initially started with training programs
to train the farmers about salinity as a
as a because it's such a high risk
factor for cropping
um and what came out of that was
actually they need just soil soil Health
Training and so
um it was amazing what the farmers could
tell you about their soil
um just from their observations like we
keep growing rice and the yields kept
going down we keep putting more
fertilizer on but the yields keep going
down but when we grow these alternative
crops Everything Changes in the next you
know the next rice crops better and and
so they they put it together they
realize that soil health is really
important but they don't know much about
it and so we have changed our training
from salinity training to soil training
soil constraint training and um and
that's we've done it and you'll have to
forgive us for just being Australian
people working with Australian farmers
and understanding what that's like uh
we've used the models that we know work
with our farm and took them to Vietnam
and the Vietnamese tell you like oh this
isn't going to work like no one's
interested in this stuff you won't get
Farmers engaged in this week look trust
me it works Farmers love this stuff and
we did it and the farmers engaged and
the diet people oh we've never seen
Farmers engaged like this you know and
so farmers are farmers they they
understand the soil they unders like
they want to know more about it if they
don't know they want to learn and so so
that was um that I don't know the bio
fund tool I'm not familiar with it but
anything that it links soil fertility or
soil health
to a farmer is is going to work I think
yeah not as long as it's Hands-On
okay two quick extra questions the
chameleon tool what's its lifespan
uh good question it depends where and in
what conditions it's being used
the creator of the chameleon is is
called um Richard sterzaka he's
wonderful and he continues to develop
the product and um takes feedback uh
from from a whole world like range of
developing countries that are utilizing
the chameleon uh he's had chameleon
sensors last one cropping season he's
had them last five cropping Seasons so
it's it's finding what parameters affect
those
um and why they would disintegrate
quicker he has work on extra durable
sensors that are thicker and he's
working on Coatings and different things
like that to you know expand their
longevity
the computer part of the sensor will you
know will last for a very long time it's
just the actual senses that go in the
ground that may need replacing and
they're they're very cheap so
one last question uh have you looked at
genetically modified crops
saline resistance
we haven't no and and there would be you
would have to do a bit of work with
finding policies
um and how that matches in the systems
okay yeah great thank you very much
thank you thank you I see it now these
chameleon sensors by the way can I ask
roughly yeah so the card the chameleon
card is about fifty dollars Australian
with that comes with three senses
already and
um the Wi-Fi is is 150 200 but looking
at
um so they're actually produced in
Africa which is where Richard started a
lot of his work in Tanzania and
countries like that trying to
um solve Water Crisis issues there which
is there's some great work that he's
doing and developed a factory
um there so there's they're working on
trying to get them the price lower each
time and more accessible for Farmers
yeah so those cards are our go-to for of
farmers because it's it's you know
economically viable for them yeah yeah I
just see a question in the chat um from
Stefan I think about natural inoculum of
the cowpie there is no current available
uh viable inoculum that's commercial in
in the Delta but we have found
nodulation and we're doing work on
identifying it and um
looking at salt tolerant rhizobium so
there's there's a space there which is
exciting and and it's great that the
cowpea that we sowed had had nodules
when we when we looked at them which is
which is great A great sign
thanks that's also another question in
the chat and that's also a question I
had regarding the salinity levels in the
different uh sites that you have you
mentioned four provinces so it's it's
probably a it's a gradient because it's
rather Upstream to Coast
um did you
I mean Target the crops to the different
levels and what would what's your how
did you do that and what are the levels
that's me answer questions
yep so in stock training they're oh they
can get up to so the Vietnamese use
grams per liter so
um the canal the sluice Gates will shut
at four grams per liter of of the water
irrigation water
so that was the basis that we used in
determining if a crop would be suitable
understanding that soil salinization
over the the you know course of the dry
season that can get a lot worse and
solute potentials and things like that
so if if a crop can't handle that
um it's sort of out of the equation but
we were finding
um Canal EC up to I think there's been
14 15 deci Siemens recorded
um we've got data that sort of says
eight and nine
um in in those areas of the peak dry
season and then
um that sort of trend follows slower the
lag with the soil yeah and so and so
using mulch and and irrigating we can we
can minimize the solute potential even
though there's salt present we can
minimize the effect of the solute
potential so we can still get the plants
to grow without that mulch there of
course you get the evaporation then
salts concentrate the solid potential
will kill the plant
um but the other thing is our because of
the nature of the problem uh it's quite
normal to grow these plants when there
is no salinity but the salinity comes as
they grow so it's the end of their you
know it's like Brook says the
reproductive phase if you get the
solution that's the problem and so the
the duration of that that crop becomes
really important because you can with
the right a short duration you can miss
the salinity risk you can actually have
your crop harvested before the salinity
comes in but where where we've done
trials in the field you know we've we've
got even though like book said like they
you'll shut the sluice gate at four
Grands per liter
um with evaporation and then even
irrigation followed by evaporation
you'll get higher salinities in the soil
and and they will harm the sensitive
crops for sure so that's in provinces
where there are sluice gate protection
we've got other provinces where the
sluice gates are so effective that you
don't get salinity coming in but you
you've you've effectively got a trapped
water source and so water scarcity
becomes an issue so salinity even though
our project is was focused on salinity
is it's actually in some provinces it's
water scarcity is the problem so there's
alternative crops are still better than
rice because it's a different risk
profile different water use and so it's
still much more sensible to grow an
alternative crop than it is to try to go
rice in the in the dry season when
you've got a limited amount of fresh
water available to you and and then
that's why the chameleons are so
important because you you optimize that
water use efficiency so you're not
wasting water and then there's more
water to to go around within those traps
enclosed systems yeah maybe you can come
in here yes sir go ahead yes um as I
also would like to acknowledge this very
nice presentation Brooke and Jason as
what I really liked was that you always
had explanations also you made it an
overview and you had always examples so
that was really nice and you also showed
us
um your own lessons you learned so I'm
really valuing this in your presentation
and I was quite triggered by one that
one of you said that it's very important
the principles of how to implement and
adopt and then I thought
um yeah is this something one should go
further with as it's it's really this
type of thinking of what is needed why
we are doing this why not that coming to
this point of uh yes uh irrigation every
day that is maybe common practice but
it's not a best practice and so this uh
working with with people in this food
system uh more looking into the
principles of how doing things so how
thinking it's through so not coming up
to solution saying okay now use beetroot
and then uh so many days before or after
that but uh yeah more go into this way
of doing things
yeah thank you yeah and it's interesting
like and and
um limit I've only really worked in
Vietnam uh as my International
experience but the farmers there
they'll see something work and just pick
up and go with it and so uh the
willingness you know you go from
literally going from hey
um let's consider growing alternative
crop instead of rice because rice is
risky and then they see it and now let's
grow two alternative crops and it's like
whoa just calm down like maybe we just
get one right first but they they're
wanting to keep going faster and faster
and so
um you know being there to be able to
support that interest and that
enthusiasm but also protect people from
perhaps the risks that come with with
changing so rapidly
um but so there's a balance there with
dealing with the individual the
individuals right I think that's the key
to it like you you've got to tap into
that enthusiasm and and uh they're
they're uh it might be their age and
stage and and who's there to farm with
them or what their goals are
um become become really important and we
you talk about learning we've spoken
about a little bit there's so much
learning involved in it but
um of course but uh when we when we see
the farmers with we're around our field
trial and then neighbors then want to
get involved and they start expanding
out
um then you start we have the it's it's
uh because if they're not going to grow
that alternative crop and they want to
grow rice well now we've got a hydrology
conflict you know because some people
want to have flooded Fields next to
something that needs to be drained and
so those issues become become important
yeah yeah and maybe
but you need the rice as a mark So and
and if you use the rice as a milk what
are you are not doing with rice that you
may have done before so then there are
always uh yeah a lot of things to uh to
be looked into whether it was one that
is very good you are causing something
else where maybe something is missing at
the end so that this is really this uh
discussions about trade-offs what what
we are using in an in what way yeah yeah
in one of the projects we've
quite interestingly com so I had a
profitability analysis combined with the
risk analysis and then you can also see
okay some some cropping systems may have
higher profit but also have a higher
risk and that's that's I mean important
to to balance
um we are running out of time I would
like to still ask you uh what's your
what are your next steps what's what's
coming next are you going for a second
phase how long is the project running
what's your do you have a scaling
strategy what is next in your vision yes
so we're we're roughly halfway through
um and like we we started in the covert
period so it was a pretty rough start
but
um luckily the team at Quinto uni
um did a lot of work
um good work that got the project loaded
off in the right direction earlier so
that was good we're about halfway
through and so what we what we are
looking at doing now is is our struggle
like Brook said in her presentation that
that fitting timing into a cropping
calendar is very crucial and so we want
to do more work around timing timing of
sewing and timing of these Land
Management practices and preparation uh
and and I think we need to probably
start factoring in some like modeling
um you know climatic conditions into
that and and factoring that into the
outcomes and sort of using our field
trials to validate those models
um so we need to do that we need to at
the moment all of our fertility is based
on what is common practice in the area
which is largely coming off what people
do if they grow Maize
um and so there's a fair bit of
optimization to be had in that space
um but yes moving forward so this
project ends in mid 2025
and so we are looking at developing a
new project
that still looks at using alternative
crops developing further on what we've
been doing like Brooks says focusing on
legumes a little bit more and of course
um Vietnam like every other country in
the world you know
um soil carbon greenhouse gas emissions
have to be factored into that and so so
um looking at the benefits that our
improved systems with these alternative
crops that deliver benefits to the
farmers but also benefits for the system
and quantifying some of those as well so
that that can be used so it's Quantified
it's known that if Farmers change to
this practice then these are the
benefits
um that come from its social as well as
you know
physical yeah
very interesting thank you I'm I'm sure
uh you'll get that uh work funded
um I also hope that we keep on uh
engaging and maybe even uh try and
formalize a collaboration uh in more
detail uh in the future
um for now thank you very much for the
presentation it was very enjoyable and
the next Delta talks I'm not exactly
sure if we have a date already
uh we have in about four weeks the
international rights Congress coming up
and the whole world of course is very
busy with that and focuses on that so
I'm not sure if that is maybe in the way
and we need to find an alternative date
we will announce that ASAP
so thank you everybody for participating
uh
thanks for the opportunity it's great to
see you again too
thank you okay thank you bye thank you
bye-bye thank you bye bye
thank you
foreign